christian is that that's uh adam sandler
mr deeds
shirt yes it is that's fantastic thank
you thank you one of my favorite movies
of all time it's one of my favorite
movies i like it
i love that movie apparently adam
sandler took his family to ihop and the
lady worked in the front
turned him down yeah wait why i don't
know busy
so basically the uh hostess saw that a
man and his family came in trying to get
a table
it was a busy day so they had only a
they had a 30 minute wait
adam sandler basically left but the
hostess didn't realize that it was adam
sandler because of the mask
she noticed later when a co-worker told
her they looked through cctv
confirmed it was him and people uh
basically saw on tick tock went viral
and they love adam sandler for not
flexing his celebrity card being like oh
well i'm adam sandler can you see me now
oh wow just so humble
i like that uh mr dee's has a very
special spot in my heart because i
right after i saw the movie i asked out
a girl what year is that
what's up let's see how old chappelle is
that uh that was uh that was
no that was not 2003. mr deeds was uh
jen has a computer i remember when i
asked her out
it was 2000 2002. did she say yes so you
were she said yes
no i called you on the phone oh
so you're 15 you take this young philly
dove to mr deets
i didn't take her i went with my homies
okay and then after the movie we were
all hyped because it was a good movie
yeah
and then where they were like hey man
you know how you like uh such-and-such
what was her name give her a first name
it's the girl that got me in the
cheerleaders give me something super no
her name's marissa yeah
yeah so i i remember come on now where's
the lopez though
okay yeah that's fine yeah uh
well she's married now yeah but uh you
definitely aren't looking up your
friend's list right now yeah i know
she i remember yeah we were all hype i
remember we were uh
at our junior high just walking around
we would do that like late at night just
you guys walk around
with each other like hey yeah it was
just like homies man and then but you
liked it
yeah because i i i remember i bought her
a gift for her birthday oh damn
i went to a victoria's secret not [ __ ]
up
would go to victoria's secret and buy
the girl that they like or their
girlfriend the perfume or the lotion
i thought
no i've always been like a lover i've
never been like oh you got some lotion
perfume yeah strawberries and champagne
well yeah and then uh they're like man i
think you've got it
you know what i mean your buddies were
hyped yeah i was like yeah i was like i
got this
i think you did yeah so my homie gave me
his phone he had the flip phone he was
the only one with a cell phone
yeah whatever it was probably and then
uh i called her up
and i was like hey i was i was wondering
if you uh
did you just go right you went right to
it i went right to it
she went hey what's up girl
uh i was wondering you know if if you'd
be my girlfriend
and then she was and she said she's like
oh
not right now maybe sometime in the
future and i told my voice
though uh she's married two kids uh
yeah uh man shoot or shoot though
dude that's how i was though i didn't
know like there has to there had to be a
build up
to like when you talk to someone you got
a date you got it like there's a build
up what's that
you asked but i was just like there was
a build
no and then we were like we were just
hyped on the movie because it was so
dope
and they were like hey man you know
because we were sitting there we were
sitting at the school in the in the
[ __ ]
grass area or whatever and they were
like yo you need to [ __ ] do it man
you need to ask her ain't nothing
like i never i don't even think she knew
i liked her until i [ __ ] asked cuz
y'all was just homies right cause that's
how i was i would just ask out
was it awkward on uh monday when he saw
her no because i'm not an awkward
[ __ ]
you know yeah i mean yeah
yeah you're like
i remember one time i asked a girl in
that i said uh that's it in front of me
in math class
she uh i wrote it on a piece of paper i
said hey we'd be my girlfriend what
grade is this
that was seventh grade i remember i
remember she she looked at it
crumbled it up and just [ __ ] threw it
right back in yeah oh
yeah i mean she died rightfully so she
she had every right today not like
writing
i was i'm like just a lover and then all
of a sudden i was just like
this and now you've got one now that i
was like yeah some talents
i've asked out 50 women and narrowed it
down to one now i haven't asked out 50.
but i've asked that a lot
and did you ask your current girl out
was it or was it just organic
uh no i was like hey will you be my
girlfriend but after how long
uh you guys are going on hikes and [ __ ]
nonstop right
you guys were hanging out for four
months yeah yeah that's a good game and
see at the
when i was younger i thought you was
just like oh yeah you just if you like a
girl you just ask her to be your
girlfriend that's kind of what you do
when you're that young boy no
at 15. sound like you're asking out some
[ __ ] i know i was especially like
crumpled up the note and threw it away
i mean she had every right no not really
she could be cool listen i was a [ __ ]
nut
oh you're a while well you were drinking
back then though uh and junior high yeah
i was drinking
come on now great you were drinking in
seventh grade yeah first
yeah first you're drinking wild turkeys
dude that i'm telling you that's the
first thing i got drunk off it was wild
turkey
yeah yeah yeah so they're probably yeah
they're like oh
yeah i don't know if he's stable for us
yeah and i would get in fights all the
time i was rowdy
i'd cuss out teachers and i'm like and
then i'd be like hey you wanna be my
girlfriend
with a victorian secret like this makes
sense
i didn't know you're getting hammered
off wild turkey in seventh grade
of
yeah and then like i remember i used to
ask this girl to dance at junior high
it was to that [ __ ] ginger wine my
whole life
has changed we bought it oh yeah uh ally
and jojo
no no no no no yeah you're thinking a
different one so what happened
uh so you were absolutely already the
same girl yeah
uh the that song started playing and i
was like oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah you're all dressed up at the time
and [ __ ]
all uncomfortable in khakis bro and so i
walked up to her i was like hey
uh you know you want to dance you know
and she was like
oh my feet hurt i was like oh okay cool
cool cool
same song is playing she's dancing with
another [ __ ] dude
oh bruh bro is this your friend now
is she my friend now yeah no no no this
is a different this is a girl that
crumpled up the paper
damn you stayed on it though i stayed on
now are you hammered at this party
uh no after oh yeah after what
what chill hammered hey
hey you like genuine [ __ ] yeah girl
we're all drinking right now like you
weren't drinking
[Applause]
grew up in mesa that's why it makes it a
little different yeah when did you have
your first drink he's never had a drink
never had a drink oh
yeah he still has it don't drink a smoke
i respect that
but see but like dude were you asking
out girls like that like were you just
like
hey will you be my girlfriend oh yeah
you see you did the what yeah shoot her
shoot man shoot her
back then yeah shoot her shoe shoot a
shirt
with with nerf guns you know back then i
was shooting
how were you when you got your first
kiss though oh [ __ ] i was 16. you're
sixteen that's good
it's late in the game i mean yeah what
hey [ __ ] off guys
spells i had my first kid kissed at 27.
no one can relate to it no first kiss at
26.
no one held hands with a girl first time
at 29
i had my first kiss in sixth grade it
was this mix girl she was so
bad and she it was she was aggressive i
remember she kissed me in front of all
my home oh she grabbed you
yeah like just she had these big lips
she was mixed
fine as [ __ ] there you go we were both
in sixth grade chill
so then i remember she kissed me in
front of my friends after some art class
and then i remember my friend cameron
wilson pulled my pants down from
everybody while you were getting
while you were making out hey it was so
embarrassing let that thing pop out
man that's the thing i hate it on you
cameron i got a big one
what a hater though yeah what a hair i
wrote a lovely well how old were you
i wrote a love letter in sixth grade
telling my crush she was in eighth grade
and i wrote like the other oh you always
liked alderweireld always like older
women yeah and all right
like this is like usher nice and slow
was popping so i just wrote
the whole third verse like you know they
call me m a
l i k b a
and i wrote all that and i put in a
locker and it was so many typos
in that letter
she's like she's like uh the answer is
no
but i think i can help you with your
english she became my
locker i mean
everything yeah she was i was like yo
did you hear the effort
did you get my letter and she was like
yeah were y'all were y'all bad students
like me
no no no i was just i was trying to go
to university of colorado so i
i got good grades i had to give you
which i'm wearing you're not i'm talking
about like behavior-wise
you never never no no it's too focused
on this y'all [ __ ] liars
anyone can connect with me in here okay
you were a bad student christian no i
i got like good grades i was just when i
was young
i was out of control like in seventh
grade like i got into like
three none of them were my fault i'll
admit that but i was like
like i was having eraser fights like
with my friends like
in the middle of class we just are
humming [ __ ] at each other the youngest
yeah yeah like i was getting like i got
into a couple
fights in seventh grade but like i
wasn't like like me and my friends like
it was the same friend group since like
second grade so
we were just very small a town very
small school
we were just out of control you're
trying to swing at your teachers
no i didn't even know any of y'all had a
full fight
none of you yeah okay i never have a
food
uh you had your first girlfriend win
i'm like chapelle my first girlfriend
probably
20 no 23 24. oh
late yeah even when you but weren't
before them weren't you like trying to
dance and sing and [ __ ]
no so i'm the only reason i had
girlfriends because they
did the move because i was so i was
super super shy they had to be magical
yeah yeah was you bigger at the time
oh no so when i was in my 20s or you
know mid
early 20s wait you were
bigger 300 pounds 300 pounds
the chin got shredded you just stopped
yeah it got shredded
it's one of my favorite pictures on
earth
and once you have your first boyfriend
kat uh my first
boyfriend was in seventh grade
that's about normal yeah and then i got
a boyfriend in high school and like kept
him forever
yes you did kept him
for way too long i appreciate that i've
had my first girlfriend now because yeah
i was just too crazy
a little more mature now yeah a lot more
mature you know what i mean
you guys can be talking i'll look
forward so no wait no one tried to swing
at a teacher
no dude we don't play that [ __ ] doug
y'all don't play that [ __ ] i i mean i
went playing
hey dope ass teacher stuff we can't have
my teachers are fine
uh sixth grade you're a crush on your
teacher yeah i i had a crush on my
fourth grade teacher i was like ah
there's no
christian look at this that was chin
god damn thank you
proud of you now but damn are those
those are overalls you're wearing no no
it was a those
that's not overall that's what jenko's
oh god he got it
she looks so scared i'm gonna have to
bleep her
not bleep her but blur her face this is
from dallas in dallas
no this is here in orange county oh in
orange county it's sadie hawkins once
again
the girl had that i remember sadie
hawkins
yeah mm-hmm i went to a couple dances i
got down she
was dead it's just this picture so crazy
because
i remember it looks like i'm a
ventriloquist i'm not even kidding like
i'm like a puppet
flat factory right away you go bro i
figure out what you look like i'm like
what this from a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song